ab ersten juli sinkt die mehrwertsteuer
auf 16 oder auch bei den verminderten
satz auf 5 ist das für mich jetzt bin
ich jetzt gut beraten einfach mit
anschaffungen jetzt zu warten oder gibt
es dann doch vielleicht doch um zu wenig
geld bei größeren anschaffungen schon
denn wenn ich jetzt ein kaufvertrag
beispielsweise schließe nach dem ersten
sieg
dann wird es ja günstiger wenn jetzt die
mehrwertsteuerreduzierung auch an die
kunden weitergegeben wird
denn das ist ja auch so ein bisschen so
der knackpunkt die frage ist ja ob
tatsächlich jetzt die preise reduziert
werden oder ob es bei diesen preisen wie
wir sie bisher haben ob es dabei
sozusagen brutto bleibt so dass eben der
anbieter diese reduzierung irgendwie
haben möchte oder versucht zu bekommen
das wäre dann im grunde genommen eine
preiserhöhung eine netto preiserhöhung
und wenn man jetzt also eine größere
anschaffung hat dann kann man warten
damit man die etwas geringere
mehrwertsteuer bekommt wenn man sie denn
dann bekommt aber man kann auch
versuchen jetzt schon mehr rabatte
rauszuschlagen denn man kann ja sagen na
ja was passiert denn wenn ich bis zum
ersten sieg wartet da wird zwar billiger
und da werden viele verkäufer natürlich
sagen okay ich gebe dir jetzt diese drei
prozent die du eben im nächsten monat
spaß die gebe ich dir jetzt schon mit
der folge dass man jetzt schon kaufen
soll
kaufen kann aber man sollte unbedingt
auch ein bisschen mehr handeln also es
hat sich wirklich ein guter tipp wenn
halt auch diese firmen so ein bisschen
darauf angewiesen sind also auch das
thema werbung wenn es halt um größere
summen gibt also auto möbel oder was
weiß ich ein carport oder so da bietet
sich das an
die nächste frage und zwar meine reise
ist im herbst ich habe aber jetzt schon
vor corona gebucht bekomme ich dann mein
geld zurück weil ja die reise in die
zeit fällt wenn die mehrwertsteuer
reduziert ist
das sind der rechnungen die schon
bezahlt sind und rückwirkend haben wir
da keine änderungen das ist nur wenn wir
jetzt vorschüsse haben und es ist noch
gar nicht die endrechnung dann habe ich
dir bei der endrechnung haben wir dann
den reduzierten mehrwertsteuer betrag
mit der folge dass die anzahlung die ich
vielleicht vorher noch geleistet habe
zu dem alten mehrwertsteuer betrag
daneben voll brutto angerechnet wird auf
die endrechnung und wenn die endrechnung
dann einen geringeren mehrwertsteuer
betrag enthält dann ist natürlich dieser
betrag anzurechnen mit der folge dass
eben diese leistung dann auch günstiger
werden
das heißt aber ich habe wahrscheinlich
schon bezahlt letztlich oder es kann ja
auch im ferienhaus gehen oder um einen
ganz normalen flug wenn halt alles
soweit schon abgegolten ist werde ich
wahrscheinlich kein geld zurück zu
bekommen
naja wenn das leistungs verhältnis zu
sagen schon abgewickelt das also der
vertrag sozusagen schon durchgeführt ist
dann haben wir ja die problematik dass
sozusagen das geld schon bezahlt ist
aber die inanspruchnahme der leistung
erst zu einem späteren zeitpunkt
stattfindet und da ist natürlich
schwierig das jetzt wieder
rückabzuwickeln
denn im grunde genommen kommt es
allerdings auf den leistungs zeitraum an
das heißt auf genau den zeitraum zu dem
eben die leistung erbracht wird das ist
bei handwerkern beispielsweise so da
kommt es gar nicht so sehr auf die frage
an ob wir jetzt die leute die die
rechnung schon stellen sondern es kommt
auch die frage an wann ist die leistung
vollbracht und wenn ich erst im juli
etwas abrechne was aber schon im mai
schon vollendet war dann muss ich den
alten mehrwertsteuer betrag nehmen und
alles was danach erst vollendet wird
dann den neuen mehrwertsteuer betrag
also dass es bei reisen natürlich
ähnlich wäre das heißt wenn ich erst die
leistung er später in anspruch nehmen
dann müsste das eigentlich reduziert
werden aber hier ist er die problematik
dass das leistungsverhältnis jedenfalls
das zahlungsverhalten ist schon längst
abgewickelt ist